- [DROCK] Wait, where's my phone.
Oh yeah, I left in Gary's office.
By the way, this is why
I love Instagram DM.
I saw a video that a fan had made,
and I reached out to them on DM,
shot them a message, and they
were like, yeah cool, use it.
And so, yo Andy, you
ready to do your part?
- Yeah, let's do it man.
What's up Vayner Nation, it's Andy,
brand director for Gary Vaynerchuk.
Did you watch it?
- Yeah I'm watching it right now, but.
- [DROCK] What do you think so far?
- It's really good.
I love the fact that he
was talking about offense,
'cause that mindset is
the mindset of the year.
- So we're trying to come
up with the best versions
of DailyVee to post with Gary being
off the grid during the holidays.
We found this motivational video
from the Mulligan Brothers,
it has a million views.
When DROCK texted Gary he said,
I'm not going to intro it, why don't you,
DROCK and Iris do it?
So that's what we're doing.
My meta take on it was that
Gary's talking about perspective
and offense and everything
and that's exactly what these guys did.
Like, they just didn't have content,
so they went out and found it online,
cut it up and got a
million views out of it.
There's so much opportunity if your head
is in the right space to go and take it.
- I love the key points of everything,
and then adding on top of the music,
it's good, and then it
has good b-roll in it so,
excited for you all to see it.
- And it just comes down to perspective,
and if this video doesn't
give you that perspective,
you're shit out of luck.
(upbeat music)
- I think so many people are
keyboard activists, right?
Everybody's good at sending a tweet about
how the world should be,
and nobody's doing anything about it,
and that is just, very much, human nature.
(slow dramatic music)
- [DROCK] We've gotten soft, as a culture.
- Yes, of course we've gotten
soft as a culture in the U.S.
Because the U.S. has had
an incredible 200 year run.
This is just what happens.
So as a culture, I can't speak for people
that live in the Amazon River
and I can't speak for people
that still live in Belarus
but the American culture is soft
and that's a great thing.
That means there's been
enormous amounts of prosperity.
But let's not be naive.
People, literally, complain when somebody
gives then the wrong amount of extra cream
in a Starbucks $6 coffee.
(slow dramatic music)
My lack of interest in
complaining is so high
and when I watch what
people complain about,
it breaks my heart because they
completely lack perspective.
I generally believe my happiness
and optimism comes from my perspective.
I even, in political unrest
times, like right now.
A lot of people are
very bent out of shape.
But the reality is that
it's just never been better
to be a human being.
That's just the truth.
That's just data. That's reality.
And it's just a very fun time to be alive.
I think the way people look
at the world right now,
because it's such an incredible time,
is actually the quickest
tell to who they are.
If you think it sucks,
or that it's bad, you are
loosing pessimistic DNA.
And if you think it's
awesome and phenomenal,
you have optimistic, winning DNA
and I believe that to be true.
And so that's where we're at.
We're beating ourselves up.
Like everybody sucks at something, right?
We all have shortcomings
ans we all have strengths.
And for me, it's like, why
don't we just audit that?
Why don't we just look at it that way?
And be like, alright, I'm good at this
but I'm not good at that.
And then I only focus
what I'm good at right?
I don't dwell that I can't
fix shit around the house.
I call somebody to fix it.
I'm not like I'm not a man.
I don't give a fuck.
I don't get it.
I also think it's awesome that I'm so
emotionally stable and I'm
the emotional backbone of everybody.
Is that what a dude's supposed to do?
These cliches, these
stereotypes, they're so silly.
I'm fully in love with myself.
But I'm also fully in love
with everybody else too.
It goes both ways.
I tell people to buy into
me, that work for me.
It's 'cause I buy into them first.
I don't need anybody
to gain trust with me.
It's there.
I believe the human race
is so grossly under rated.
We are good.
Of course we have some bad.
There's fucking seven billion of us.
But when you look at our
net score, it's bonker shit.
Do you know how much damage we could
be doing to each other on an
hourly basis and we don't?
We're still here. We won.
We're the alpha being
and we've figured out
how to stay together.
This is insane when you think about it.
And yet everybody wants to dwell
on like somebody said something mean.
(slow dramatic music)
If you want to be an anomaly,
you have to act like one.
People want all these special things
to happen but then they're
acting like everybody else.
And that gets into the
Saturdays on, in your 20's.
Or just like taking risks
or things of that nature.
If there's anything they take away,
it's like look, you're
gonna only be so pretty,
you're only gonna be so smart.
There's things that are gonna be natural
and then there's things that
you can actually control.
I do believe and I don't know
if I'm right or wrong, I don't.
But I do believe that work
ethic is a taught behavior.
It's something that you
do have more control over.
You know what really
sealed the deal for me?
Getting healthier.
I was 38 years old and it
didn't come natural to me.
It didn't come natural to me at all.
I hate the gym. I hate it now.
I hate it. I don't like it.
I don't want to do it.
But I knew it was important
and somewhere around midway
through being 38 years old,
I got serious, I figured out my system.
I made the financial commitment.
And I've won right?
And I'll never loose again because
the system was I needed to be accountable
to another human being.
So it was about Mike and now Jordan,
whoever else is my trainer.
I'm doing it, almost weirdly more,
to not let them down.
(slow dramatic music)
I feel like there's a shift
that can make people work harder.
The big one that I push
is you're gonna die.
To me, life is broken down
into complaining and not.
So if you're not complaining,
well then I have no advise for you.
I'm pumped. You did it.
I have friends who make $42,000 a year,
work nine to four, kind of,
with an hour and a half lunch
and 45 minutes of YouTube and 10 minutes
of bullshitting and an hour of complete
wasted time in a meeting.
So they're working six hours a week right?
But they're pumped.
And they text me.
These are high school friends.
And they'll text me how happy they are
to be the coach of their
kid's baseball team.
That's amazing.
In fact, that seems very obvious to me.
That's right.
You know what's super weird?
I'm actually weirdly envious.
It sounds cool, in theory.
The grass is always greener right?
Far less pressure.
All that time with my
kids, that would be cool.
There's just all these
things that I can justify.
But I have friends who
have 100 million dollars
in the bank because of Facebook's IPO
who complain, who are still hungry,
who want to do even more,
who will complain to me 'cause they know
I work a lot about no work life balance
and they don't get to spend enough
time with they're family.
And I'm like, you have a
hundred million dollars.
You could stay home.
You're in control.
Don't complain about it.
You've made that choice.
Don't bullshit me.
You want to spend more
time with your family?
Spend more time with your family.
I'm trying to be very careful about
what I'm saying versus what I'm doing.
Because that's how you get exposed.
I don't mean people calling you out
and being like, you suck.
I mean to yourself.
I don't want to be exposed by myself.
It's looking yourself in the mirror
and saying, "Am I doing this right?"
So, to me, there's so many people
that are talking shit about how big
of an entrepreneur they're gonna be
and how much they're gonna achieve
and they don't work on weekends.
I worked every Saturday of my 20's.
And I talk to 20 year old
entrepreneur every single day.
Lately I've been saying to them,
"This Saturday, you're
gonna have more time off
"then I've had in my
entire 20's on a Saturday."
So before you tell me how you're gonna
be bigger than me, start thinking about
what you're actually doing.
(slow dramatic music)
I'm careful to not give advise
that I know is uniquely something
that I was gifted with.
How do I tell you that oh here's how
it actually works and it
almost started happening.
It didn't happen.
I actually get goose bumps, like actually.
Real heavy goose bumps when I hear
something that I know feels right.
What's the advise there?
Hey Johnny, start getting goosebumps.
There's certain things that I can't
talk about because I know
they're not practical.
They're intuitive to me.
(slow dramatic music)
I plan to instill kindness into my kids.
I plan on instilling
perspective into my kids.
I plan on just being a good human being.
I plan on making sure they don't use
their parents wealth and micro fame
and leverage to impose
on any other person.
I was petrified of that.
If my kids try to punk their friends
on my shit, I'm gonna
beat the fuck out of them.
That's just loser DNA.
You didn't do that.
I'm not obsessed with tactics.
I'm obsessed with religion.
I have a lot of wealthy friends,
at this point, who think it's smart
for them to sit first class
put the kids in coach, it's a tactic.
They send their kids to Africa
to build a school for a week.
It's a tactic.
It's like my friends that
love the environment.
The number two sector in the world
that is hurting the environment
is the fashion industry.
When you run the math of what's doing bad
to the earth, it's the number two
industry behind, I don't even want
to say it 'cause I'm not
sure if it's gas and oil.
The number two industry, this
and this I know for fact,
is the fashion industry.
So all my fancy friends
who love the environment,
are they willing to give up
their fucking Louie bags?
Let's see right?
So I think people talk shit.
You let them sit coach
and you went first class
but you went to Hawaii
and ate at all the best.
You can't pick and choose.
To me it's binary.
I don't want to be a hypocrite.
My big thing is like look,
you need to be kind.
Being mean is just non
negotiable in our family.
And then you just need
to not be full of shit.
If you want to look at Daddy's melon
and you want to say what I did
to my dad's and that was a big mountain
for an immigrant like
wow, dad did it right?
If you want to say I'm gonna climb that
and I'm gonna climb bigger, awesome.
I'm pumped, I'm weirdly
not cheering for you 'cause
(man laughs)
I'm just a weirdly competitive dude.
This is actually something
I'm not proud of.
I'm comfortable saying this
and I believe this is a flaw.
But I don't want my kids
to beat me, I don't.
I hate saying it.
I know this is where I get in trouble.
People will take one little clip
from one video interview and they're like,
"You're bad."
It's just my truth.
I don't want to bullshit you guys.
I'm that competitive.
(slow dramatic music)
I just want them to be all in on them.
I don't need them to be an entrapuener,
I don't need them to make me proud,
they don't need to go to Harvard,
they don't need to do shit.
They need to be themselves, all in
and they need to be kind and good.
(slow dramatic music)
Everybody thinks they're stuff is so good.
Every day Gary, my Instagram's so on fire.
It's so awesome.
Why am I not gaining followers?
'Cause it's not awesome.
Think, we all think our stuff is the best.
I get that.
But yeah, that would be my advise.
Only because that, also, is liberating.
To me, everything's about breathing.
To me, everything is about take
full ownership for everything.
And then everything gets easy.
'Cause then you're in control.
And then learn how to love to lose.
I think that's how entrepreneurship,
that's how life is.
We all have loses.
I like loses. I love adversity.
I like the climb.
I like the chip on my shoulder.
I like when people are
like, "Oh I knew it."
"He's not that good."
I'm even weirdly scared as I continue
to ascend and I'm getting popular
and what did he say?
The marketing leaning,
people start putting
these words in front of my name.
I'm like, am I gonna sabotage
myself to re correct this?
I like adversity.
Yeah, all on me.
I enjoy loses.
Now, all of a sudden, like what?
You become completely invincible.
I feel invincible.
I really, genuinely, outside of the health
of myself and 20 people feel
100% invisible as a person.
I know what my intent is.
I want to do good at
nobody else's expense.
I'm far from perfect, we all are.
It's just easy.
It feels very light to live life.
I'm just in a good mood.
(slow dramatic music)
Them home but I think modern day parents
and most parents do not do that.
I think they focus on
dumb shit like grades.
Because they are insecure
and they want to put the bumper sticker
that their kids went to Stanford.
It's real fucked up when you really
think about what's actually happening.
So much of it is misery loves company.
Or people reflecting of
what's inside of them.
(slow dramatic music)
- What is the impact that you want
to have on the world?
- Same thing that attracts so many
of millions of people to people
that are selling bullshit.
Those same people are attracted to me.
And what I want to do is suffocate out
all those other people
and become the alpha of that entire world
of people that are
hoping and are desperate
to look at me and what I want to do
is inspire two 14 year old girls
in Kansas City, right now,
to build a billion dollar company
on having a bunch of employees
hugging each other in the halls.
I think that Steve Jobs came along,
became an icon but the sad part
of that narrative was he did not
treat his employees well.
He became an icon and the narrative became
he got the most out of people
by being a jerk and that
became romanticized.
And a lot of people in
Silicone Valley today,
run companies where they're mean
because they think that's
the right thing to do
because they put Steve Jobs on a pedestal.
I want my pedestal moment.
I want to become that big
and what I want to come from that
is that kids that aren't even born today,
think that they can build a
five billion dollar company
and be a great guy or a great gal.
I want to build the biggest
building in town, ever,
by just building the
biggest building in town.
While I think most people try to tear
down everybody else's building.
So I think positivity and good
is practical advise to building an empire
and I want to be the poster child
of the person that built the biggest,
baddest, empire and did it by being
a good dude along the way.
And not everybody's gonna be happy
about everything that I did
but if it's 97% of people talking good
behind your back, that's a real legacy.
And I want to do it in a pop culture way.
I'm gonna do it anyway.
People have done that before.
Just so you know,
there's plenty of people.
Warren Buffet's a really good dude.
There's plenty of people
that have done that.
There's a difference.
I want to do it and I
want to be a rock star.
And that's where you influence people.
I want to do it but I also want
to be the most popular.
And so then that person's like,
I want to be him so I guess I'll be nice.
I want to literally take people
who have DNA that's kind of nice
and make them more nice because
they think that's how I became big.
So I basically want to trick
the business world into becoming kinder.
(slow dramatic music)